بمقدار 135 الف ضعف من هذا الانفجار يبلغ
حجم ترسانه العالم النوويه ترسانه اخذه
بالازدياد مع زياده التوتر بين اقطابها
ففي احدث تقرير لمرصد حظر الاسلحه النوويه
ومقره النرويج فان المخزون النووي مطلع
العام الحالي زاد بمقدار 136 راسا نوويا
ليبلغ
12,512 راسا نوويا منها
2936 راسا احيلت الى التفكيك في حين ان
9576 راسا متاحه للاستخدام من قبل الجيوش
قوتها التدميريه مجتمعه تزيد عن 135 الف
مره من قنبلته هيروشيما
السباق هو وفقا للمرصد بلغ اعلى مستوياته
منذ الحرب البارده حيث تاتي زياده في
السنه الاخيره جراء مواصله دول خمس توسيع
مخزونها النووي وهي الصين روسيا كوريا
الشماليه وباكستان والهند ومنذ التاسع
والعشرين من مارس الحالي بلغ عدد الدول
الاطراف معاهده حظر الاسلحه النوويه 68
دوله وقعت 27 دوله اخرى على المعاهده
لكنها لم تصدق عليها بعد وهذا يعني ان 4
دول فقط تحتاج الى التوقيع او الانضمام
قبل ان تصل المعاهده الى 50% من جميع
الدول
مقلقه الزياده بينما كان الوضع عليه قبل
حرب اوكرانيا وما بعدها يقول محرر مرصد
حظر الاسلحه النوويه جريت اوستارن سباق ان
لم يتوقف فسنشهد زياده في العدد الاجمالي
للاسلحه النوويه لم نشهده منذ الحرب
البارده وربما اسوا